hello friends I'm Lucy and welcome to in
two minutes as you probably saw from the
sponsorship bumper this week's episode
is brought to you by Samsung and gear VR
just one of the many players in the
ever-growing VR game which has been
around for a lot longer than you'd think
with the first true head mounted VR
display being invented back in the 60s
with various incarnations being released
over the years with varying levels of
success
sorry Virtual Boy but it was the crazily
successful oculus Kickstarter just three
short years ago that got everyone
excited about virtual reality again
here's what the future holds since its
Kickstarter the now Facebook owned
oculus rift has been tweaked honed and
improved upon and its consumer model is
ready to launch in early 2016 with a
number of games applications and social
platforms ready to roll with rift
support but it's not just oculus
releasing a headset next year valve is
partnered with smartphone manufacturer
HTC to co-produce HTC vive headsets
which allows you to actually walk around
and paint in virtual space as you can
see by my gormless expression it's quite
an experience and it's set to launch in
April
PlayStation are also entering the market
with PlayStation VR let's face it
Morpheus was a cooler title but it's
still gonna have a slew of games like
until dawn rush of blood multiplayer
shooter rigs and even Tekken 7 will
support it although they're technically
mixing augmented with virtual reality
and technically they're maybe not even
out in 2016
microsoft's hololens headset beams
holograms out into the real world and
its tech demos have been incredibly
impressive with the ability to beam
applications like Skype and games like
Minecraft onto walls and tables so you
can basically be the real-life Tony
Stark without the fancy suit so those
are the headset but what else can the
future hold
well how's about profit interaction
oculus touch launching a few months
after the headset uses loads of we
infrared LEDs to track your hand
movements and provides touch or haptic
feedback so you can reach out and
actually touch things in the virtual
world and as for other senses while a
company called feel real has developed a
mask that hits the spot it projects gust
of wind
Heat's off sprays water mist and even
releases since sea
can smell your games there's a sentence
I never thought I'd say but there's
other things that VR can be used for
than just gaming it's already used in
treatment for various mental health
conditions including phobias and
post-traumatic stress disorder it allows
patients to gradually be exposed to
things that they fear their safe
controlled space architects can use it
to visualize and create buildings and
incredibly even surgeons can be trained
in VR so do you think VR is going to
become a part of our everyday lives are
you excited for the next bounce of tech
or do you think it's just not gonna be
as successful as everyone hopes let me
know in the comments section below or
look at some exciting upcoming the our
titles be sure to check out the gist
this week and to find out how VR
actually works take a look at reality
check this Friday on GameSpot calm